hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
article 7 of question 46 of the Prima
secunda the summative Thomas Aquinas is
raising a very important question about
anger on the one hand and Justice and
Injustice on the other and it's
translated in the black Friar Edition as
our anger and Justice concerned with the
same object
which technically speaking I I suppose
you could say is correct a more literal
translation of utram
would be weather anger
is against
those things or those people
uh only to which Justice pertains
and so you know it does have this sense
of being directed at the same objects
like intending the same targets you
could say
um but it's not exactly the same and we
should be careful given that anger has
the object of Revenge and there's other
ways of using the term object now this
is an interesting article in that there
are three really substantive arguments
given for why anger and Justice would
maybe overlap to some extent in what
they're directed towards but not
completely
coincide and they have to do with things
that previous writers had remarked on
about anger so the first one starts out
by saying Justice is not possible
between a human being and things that
are lacking
reasons a devoid of reason is another
way of talking about it and
Thomas you know in this arguments as
well you know sometimes people get angry
at non-rational things he gives a couple
examples a writer will throw down his
pen perhaps he's actually talking from
experience there as a writer a writer
will beat their horse and so we've got
you know inanimate objects that we get
angry at we have animals that one could
get angry at we could substitute another
thing in there maybe plants you know
that are living but not sentient right
all of these are irrational things
and so he goes on and he says that um
therefore anger doesn't have only as a
Target those towards whom Justice is
possible Justice is only possible
towards rational beings we get angry at
all sorts of beings so the scope of
anger would be wider than that of
justice and it would include the things
that that Justice is directed to so
that's the first argument
the second argument
says that there is no justice between a
human being and themself or between a
human being and their own property
According to Aristotle in the
nicomicayan ethics this is in book five
of course where there's this famous
discussion of whether you can do
Injustice to yourself
and so in a strict sense you can't right
you can only do it Injustice to another
person and he's already talked about his
own property so he's not going to worry
about that because your own property
would be things that are lacking reason
what about yourself can you be angry at
yourself can you have Injustice towards
yourself and he says so you can't have
Injustice to yourself or justice but you
can get angry with yourself people do
this all the time and he brings up a
repentant Sinner and then he brings up a
a Psalm that I don't think really proves
this case be you angry and sin not IRAs
right but he's drawing from this the
conclusion anger is not restricted to
those with whom a relationship and
Justice is possible so in the first one
it was you can't be just or unjust
inanimate things you can get angry at
them we do all the time and the second
um you
can get angry at yourself but you can't
be just to yourself so once again uh
anger has got a wider scope than Justice
what about the third one
this is a very interesting one and again
he's going to invoke Aristotle Aristotle
makes this important distinction between
anger on the one hand and hatred and
Aristotle claims that hatred is against
classes of people you you could be you
can hate an individual but you hate them
as a member of a class so you hate them
as a thief or as an adulterer or as a
despised group that you can't stand or
something like that if you have you know
prejudice against a group
anger Aristotle says is always against
individuals it could be against multiple
individuals but it's not against a Class
A Generous right or a community toss and
so he says that um the state can wrong
an individual but you you cannot become
angry at a entire class A gayness only
at a single individual so one who is not
angered properly at those who are
objects of justice and Injustice the
state can do wrong to you but you can't
you can't be angry at the state you can
hate the state but you can't actually be
angry at it or a group of people could
bully you and you could get angry at
them individually but you can't get
angry at the entire group the group is
what's doing the Injustice to you and so
um this is the argument that's being
made
and he says on the contrary we have the
position of Aristotle okay so uh he's
going to use some Aristotelian stuff uh
against this in the the responses to
these objections but the reply is very
interesting
he says anger actually desires evil as
we've said above right uh malam
insofar in quantum
as it has the aspect of just revenge in
Quantum Hobbit rations
the reason or the aspect you Steve
Indica V right so that is saying that
um anger
it's Desiring evil insofar as this has
the aspect of just Revenge so what does
this mean
anger is directed against those towards
whom there is the possibility of Justice
or injustice how is this fleshed out he
says inflicting punishment is a matter
of Justice right and you could be
mistaken about whether it's just or
unjust right but the idea behind
inflicting punishment is to impose
Justice injuring someone what is an
injustice right so he says in virtue of
its cause the endurance of injury at the
hands of another and of the Revenge of
the angered person desires it is clear
manifestom asked that anger is concerned
with the same
people so odd quotes as Justice and
Injustice
so if that's really the case then
what's up with these arguments that were
being made
including arguments that are being drawn
from Aristotle so the response to the
first argument is going to make a useful
distinction it's going to say listen
animals get angry right and
um he says that although it's responsive
to reason anger may be found in brute
animals irrational animals that's all
the other animals except for us
uh which lack reason but
they are capable uh by a natural
instinct right so Instinct can drive
them he says
um uh in Quantum not to Raleigh
instinctive and then he says something
really interesting
moventur now
when we hear that term
imagination that's imagination that can
be translated as it is here in the black
Friar as sense knowledge but that's not
really the most accurate translation
animals have a capacity for imagination
for inference for you know drawing on
these instincts and he says that this
works for the animal kind of like reason
it stands in the place
of Reason
um
the Latin here
aliquid simile right so according to
some kind of
likeness
rationes right it does it works in a
seemingly rational way but it's not
really rational right
we humans are animals so we also have
Instinct Although our instincts are
pretty weak but
we have imagination right we have
imagination and reason and we can get
angry because of both of these so he
says because we have these Powers we can
be aroused to anger in two ways first
when an injury is perceived
just through the imagination
so I mean this could be sense perception
right it could also be us imagining that
things are happening that aren't
actually happening and so he says on
this basis you can be angered even by
irrational and inanimate objects so you
know other animals your pen the door the
wind whatever it happens to be he says
thus an animal reacts against anything
injurious because it perceives it as if
it's doing something bad to it right and
then we have the anger that can actually
arise
from reason the working of reason or at
least with reason he says reason may be
conscious of an injury in this respect
as Aristotle says there can be no anger
towards insensible objects or towards
the dead and for two reasons they feel
no pain and those who are angry want
their assailants to suffer and in their
regard revenge is out of the question
because they can't be punished so in in
when it comes to re reason leading to
anger
then we we can't actually have anger
against irrational things only things
that we can have Justice or Injustice in
relation to when it comes to our sort of
animal imagination and this sort of
thing is just triggering us and we get
angry like a dog gets angry when he pull
its tail or you know you make a face in
it and it growls at you or something
like that well then that could be
towards things that we don't have
Justice or Injustice to like our book
you know the oh look the cover opened up
oh I don't like that I'm angry at it or
something like that so that that's a
prime example right there of what he's
talking about but notice that you could
say that with imagination in a certain
respect we're kind of imagining that
that thing that inanimate thing is doing
wrong to us I can't believe that book
page came out I don't like that it
didn't something wrong to me now that's
crazy talk right
but that's the way our brains work
sometimes so that that's one possible
way of understanding it the second
argument there's no justice between a
person and themself so that you know you
can't
um say that anger and Justice have the
same scope because we do get angry at
ourselves
Thomas is going to take a kind of funny
way of resolving this
he says that Aristotle recognizes a kind
of metaphorical or you know we could say
analogous Justice and Injustice between
a person and themselves in that the
rational control of the contending and
impulse appetites these are parts that
are like working with each other so
because your your soul or your psyche or
personality has different parts you can
talk about them existing in a state of
Justice or Injustice with each other
and then he says in this sense we speak
of a person punishing themselves and
consequently of them becoming angry with
themselves now the
interesting so punishing themselves
we could say maybe the rational part
punishes the non-rational parts but
becoming angry with yourself that would
must be the contending or irascible
appetite getting angry with the rational
part or with you know the concupiscable
part
um so that's you know an interesting
thing but he says
properly speaking propriet per se
it doesn't happen that a human being
actually becomes angry with themself
known contingit aliquem and so it
doesn't happen that a person somebody
becomes angry with their very own self
that doesn't seem to be a satisfactory
resolution but that's that's what Thomas
says here
then the third one which remember the
third argument was just Justice an
injustice can be between individuals it
can involve
classes you know again us it can involve
a community to an individual so anger
can't be directed against classes or
communities only against individuals so
therefore Justice and anger would have a
different scope to them
so Thomas actually says here
that
anger is provoked by an injury suffered
through somebody's action
since all actions are done by
individuals anger is always directed
against an individual okay so this
doesn't sound good so far but then he
says if an entire community
uh injured us we would reckon it
as an individual computer
and this actually does make sense this
is how people perceive things don't they
get angry at the government when really
it's somebody at you know in some sort
of functionary cleric role who pisses
them off or uh somebody else who happens
to be a manager they don't represent the
whole government right or the the entire
state but they do get angry at that I'm
angry at the University well that's a
university is just an assemblage of
people I'm angry at the Army we're
treating it as if it is a single
individual and in that case
well you can actually get angry at a
group or at a community you're just
doing so as if it was a single
individual which would mean then that
anger would have the same
scope or same application to people and
things as does Justice and Injustice so
he's making a strong case here for anger
at least in some senses not not
necessarily the mere animal sense but
the rational sense
to have a similar scope to Justice in US